[Music]
all right let's talk about farts baby
all right so did you guys know that the
study of farting is also known as flat
ology let's watch out nope because
partying you flatulence hmm alright so
this article here is asking the question
how many times should you fart in a day
oh yeah so what answer do you guys know
Devon I don't count let's see the meat
goes like a big 104
maybe you like three yeah I'll give it a
good 10/10 yeah well there's tons so I
know like when I get hungry I a sir
having hungry farts I go be like do such
a thing for me for myopia I don't know
if it's cuz my palate start moving
shortly
I have a fart it goes and then later
gets hungry you're hungry think I need a
fart more and or if I do need a poop I
started farting - Marta - yeah I'm
thinking of a train some reason Julia
talked of volume like look seven
whatever yeah bart's
are so potent there's a corrosion on
Nagasaki even if it's just two a day
it's like oh my god a culture is
destroyed this is gonna take 50 years to
rebuild but I would say probably like
maybe 30 times 30 farts Wow
34 it's in a whole day I've heard him
fart in front I can I literally heard
this before Tiger speak holy [ __ ] what
was that this is what Tiger said in his
baby language like just was the [ __ ] was
that what was it that he actually said
and then it so I can imagine like the
subtitle speak baby I just translated it
in that moment he did yeah that mean
yeah in the moment because I was like I
just see Tyga be like walk use me even
your old baby get offended no he
actually likes it when I fart he goes he
always questions a you [ __ ]
no farts are funny from day one
every blame for a for you didn't do so I
was on a plane one time and there was
the naughtiest smell and I was unlike
one of those small planes to Vegas it
wasn't that big a deal is like it's 14
of us in a plane and all of a sudden the
most overwhelming nuttiest [ __ ] egg
for it came out of nowhere and the guy
next to me is like hey look some music
it wasn't me so I did it right back damn
I know you don't know you can't chickens
the air I blame the baby one time
because like I think I was like oh no it
doesn't need and I was with Mike I was
going to my cousin's graduation and I
was with my other older cousin that had
their baby and I was [ __ ] fired and
bro I had to poo so bad and they stank
like they [ __ ] his dick and it so my
cousins like did did the baby do the
baby no poo poo didn't check the diaper
check the type or their checking the Deb
isn't like well you know that that like
repulsive reaction that we have towards
a very stinky fart that's actually
evolutionary oh yeah so back in the day
when people had very very disgusting
smelly farts that was a sign of disease
so we got like we've all know do they
know because like rats my father died in
that the average farts is made up of
oxygen nitrogen methane and sulfur and
so sulfur is is what makes your think
tea how do we capture them they just
have a guy that's lutely don't talk
about like your son of a [ __ ] in a
college program like a [ __ ] funnel oh
yeah
and of the baddest inflates he's a key
for into my my fort one please
well mom wanting to become a doctor
sorry capture well yeah so that's how
they're saying like you know back in the
day can you imagine being a knight on a
horse and you have to fart oh [ __ ]
and the only way to let it out is like
opening your [ __ ] be little pieces
like they're attached it's so connected
yeah I figured the whole thing you're a
far too just [ __ ] stuck in me like oh
god I got open this deal at the corner
Sir Lancelot smell like [ __ ] bro that's
all I read I wish there was something
like evolutionary where we are afraid of
farts so they developed color like you
can see when it comes out so you can
avoid it look like like the blue pool
water thing - I know I'm so afraid of
peeing in peoples pool pools do people
fool ya because I'm afraid of the water
turning by just a little bit and nothing
changes the my boy you can do that I
can't do a little bit okay in my pool it
stings bro use me but yeah I don't know
man I think Bart's parts are the worst
smelling I've ever smelled in my entire
life I agree and yes this is like a
overdone topic on this channel but you
guys do not understand what you talk
about overdone stuff right now like
especially like when they will you talk
about them kissing for like five videos
I might Bart sports again 15 times but
what about the article like that's
continuing the story yeah so oh no cut
continuous story yeah yeah girl cuz I
really don't want to get into that
anyway so they're saying hear that oh
yeah to answer your question by the way
like what like how many times should
someone fart and still be considered
healthy so Bart was actually the closest
really not forty times oh sure Oh
anything up to 40 times a day is healthy
Oh hop to 40 are you saying
because all I heard was 30 30 no cuz
there's times I go far at night and when
I'm sleeping and the only reason I know
I farted is because somehow my body
pushed and then the vibration woke me up
somebody oh there's a oh [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] do you push every fart up I try to
it's like trying to pop pop up or cover
I think it's cuz you have a tight ass
thank you think about if you have an
earthquake in a very [ __ ] sedentary
area the rocks are gonna fall and so
that's what worked yeah do they gotta go
yep yeah that's way more the other than
like a flabby ass where it's like
gelatin getting having a spoon put into
it
yeah exactly which makes more noise but
it's like a balloon you know when you
when you squeeze it and pull it and it
makes more noise but a rock-hard ass is
like you know saying oh more force to
like get it out if I need to get up to
pee and I don't want to wake Gio up and
I also have to fire sometimes I'll like
pull my butt cheeks apart and they'll be
like I think we've all done that and
I've never said this publicly
ever I've never said this oh my god Oh
Mike I'm tired of it I'm so proud of
yeah yeah yeah oh my god
oh my god what I do is one night when I
go use a restroom I first get some
toilet paper are you about to [ __ ] no
I'm not [ __ ] and then like if I feel
like there's a fart there I go and I
muffle it with the toilet paper really
deal silencer get the toilet paper to
see if yet brown smoke smoke I do not
fight the way you do Bart what do you so
like it actually works good like it's
like it muffles it perfectly fine and
then silencers are illegal in California
you can't do it then once I'm done
peeing
like I throw that and then I are get
another one and then you know and I'm
done oh you you don't use the fart
muffle toilet paper to wipe well I like
sometimes I what I wrote it because I
don't want to like get infections oh
yeah right
you're not supposed to use the same from
the back to the front so like I'll fold
it and then what about when you're it
what about when your shitty like taking
a number two what are you saying like
that one
no no sign is my signs huh okay Bart um
what I'm taking this [ __ ] I just let it
rip let er rip III definitely um do the
like spread the cheeks to make it quiets
not because I don't wake up cheers yeah
but sometimes I just let them go and I
look over to see if she once allowed her
sleep right now yeah the best thing is
if I fart next to Nikki Wald Nikki's
like snoring kind of a little bit then I
feel like I'm playing like a metal gear
solid game and I got to the level steel
yeah it's like it's like you did it and
you like your stealth rating is like
yeah nobody saw you what do you do you
tiny farts with her snores she's nobody
I'm like she's unders for a certain
level somewhat okay let's let it rip a
little bit let's see how we do and then
if it comes out bad and she doesn't wake
up what your fans know so I was sleeping
over at my boyfriend's house I remember
like I was like kind of wordy like
starting to get become half awake
because of the amount of movement that
he was doing and I think like and I
think because he felt like because he
felt like I was in a deep sleep he
actually like kind of got a bit and then
like kind of crouched over to like where
my face was I'm judging him partly for
it or anything yeah well I got I
suffered pinkeye because of Bart's bar
it's watch it yeah well this is the
bathroom and then you and then do you
claim that I didn't wash my hands well
enough and I was like bull-fucking-shit
my eyes were itching before like like as
I entered into them well you knew I
farted in the bathroom I like you you
just loved the restroom and I had to
but how do you know I farted in there
get pinkeye from before now what if I
just want you flush because you don't
close the the lid when you wash so
they're all swirling around the room I
don't know but you know you know what
Bart I forgive you because like I know I
know it's because you can't prove that
there was ability are you sure I got
pinkeye from Bart whatever what whether
whether he farted or whether he and
that's my boyfriend farting on your face
no when did Nelson fart in your face I
had no idea was a long time was it the
same morning probably no no no no no no
like long time ago yeah that's from
party yesterday
Bart yeah Bart [ __ ] it up real good I
forgive Bart for giving me pinkeye
because like I mean not jq4 ijk news bar
was here I think you and Julia just get
to the right here but there was a time
after a JK film shoot at Bart Bart came
in and he was sitting around here and
then and then and she's like it wasn't
me it wasn't me and he looked at me like
I was in LA he was like if what they
mean I was like part come on that's why
your boyfriend farting your face is all
those stinky ones you've been laying in
his face but I would say there was one
other time I played bar for none of this
and there was one other time where are
my guns no no it's just this is the
other one that I never she's never
admitted yeah I never said or admitted
it was on a JK party film name and I
remember it was something that we had to
do like some sort of stink challenge and
I think like smelled like [ __ ] one name
in the grass I don't know but it was
like some sort of challenge that we had
maybe it was like a spray like a snow
rumor yeah I know you remember because
because like because it smelled really
bad right and I remember how you like
sprayed poo pourri like everywhere on
the grass right and I was like so like
that covered that smell right but then
my stomach was hurting for some reason
and there's like I had a like one of
those silent farts and I think it was
like towards the end of the day and I
remember you know why wasn't it the
actual [ __ ] spray I thought bar would
win because I still [ __ ] blame it on
me these colleges do I give you give me
the [ __ ] like Brian look like yeah
it's flowing from this like from the
spray we'll just bring more poo pourri
on it and then you're like cats breathe
out [ __ ] I was like oh you're nailing it
it was such an offense to man but those
are my only two four instances in JK
that I do best do you feel good yeah I
do
[Music]
[Music]